ganz schlechte nachrichten jetzt für
alle weiblichen albtraum reloaded fans
denn was ziehen sie einer frau vor
achtung festhalten warum das so ist und
viele andere fragen beantworten sie
jetzt im talk wie lange das der neuen
spruch mal einfach sagen es ein bisschen
wie viele interviews erzählt schon das
ist abgenutzt auf youtube einige sind
auch anders
märz 1000 video ja aber was auch ich
weiß das ist eigentlich nicht die regel
als guten interviews eine offene frage
am anfang zu stellen
aber sagt mir eine bessere frage um dem
gast die möglichkeit zu geben selber die
reise in das gespräch an sich reise ist
mit kleine reise kurz ab bei uns das ist
in der nähe des heumarktes altstadt also
ich muss an dieser stelle mal als krieg
zum danken dass ihr hergekommen sei nach
köln zwar weite reise aber die zuschauer
sehen das glaube ich gar nicht geil ist
hier hinten aussieht das haben wir nicht
ich kann das mal kurz drehen dass man
das einmal zeigen so also so sieht sie
aus kölner altstadt hammer kirche groß
st martin so heißt die kirche ja so
sieht er aus schönen köln sowie kommt
nicht aus dem norden aus der wunderbaren
stadt stadthagen
das ist in der nähe von hand
nova das sollte fast jedem ein begriff
sein aber so ein kaff also so total dorf
klein eine stunde fahrt um irgendwie in
die nächste stadt zu kommen
ja und jetzt kölner ok sich nicht
verändere
ich möchte an dieser bestand stelle man
betonen nicht ich habe gesagt er also
nicht nur für uns für die anderen
endlich mal nicht da fallen mir sofort
parallele nein ihr habt mir ein video
drehen angefangen weil weil
wir kamen vom sport damals und dann war
der abend aber noch lang und dann hatten
wir irgendwie nichts zu tun und ich
hatte eine kamera irgendwie vor einer
woche bekommen und dann haben wir
einfach so gesagt ja das mal das mal an
machen und irgendwas drehen und die
erste idee haben wir dann direkt
hochgeladen also genau genommen war so
jan hat er sein gehalt diese billig
kamera da und wir haben damit nur um die
zu testen war so gedreht und andré war
dann irgendwie auf eine
tischtennisplatte und hat da irgendwie
so ein handstand draufgemacht sich fünf
mal gedreht oder so heruntergekommen an
der kamera vorbei gegangen
unser budget doch auch irgendwie so und
dann ja und dann haben wir halt gesehen
ja sooo lustig dann haben wir mit dem
video mit dem ersten video dann
angefangen
100 100 oder so ich auf jeden fall viel
das ist so zehn prozent unserer stadt
oder so das war schon nicht schlecht
man hatte ja auch keinen plan oder so
also man hat es einfach gemacht man hat
er jetzt nicht gesagt wir machen ein
video weil das soll jetzt irgendwie 5000
klicks erreichen einfach hochgeladen
wann wurden planen raus was haben wir
nach dem ersten video gemacht erstmalig
glaubte lange zeit nicht ob danach kam
erst mal eine pause oder nicht doch
danach kam halt ein jahr pause also das
erste video hieß random dance dann kam
ein jahr pause weil wir gesagt haben wir
brauchen eine bessere kamera und damals
als schüler hatte man ja halt nicht so
viel geld und dann sollten wir eine
hd-kamera besorgen das hat halt wie
gesagt ein jahr gedauert dann kam dann
kam sieht ich muss jetzt die geschichte
erzählen diese beiden sind dann in ihren
laden gelangt ihr gelaufen und wir
hatten uns was zusammengespart irgendwie
so ich weiß nicht 200 euro oder so in
einem jahr keine
und dann haben die einfach die erstbeste
hd kamera bei einfach fett hd dran stand
haben die die einfach gekauft
ich habe immer gesagt nee nee nee das
ist totaler schrott ihr kauft die nicht
und dann kamen die damit einfach unser
erspartes war weg ja und dann hat sich
rausgestellt der ton war irgendwie so
dass man uns nicht mal richtig verstehen
konnte glaube ich so die ganze zeit als
obmann vor allem ventilator sitzt ja
dann war das ersparte weg und dann ich
weiß gar nicht ob wir waren mit damit
dann erst mal viel gedreht um auf jeden
fall haben wir da dann mama zwar das
glaube ich 2010 bei secret talent
teilgenommen mit einem video the black
box hieß das und das war so voll wird
liedern die unter irgendeiner lizenz
standen und das wurde sofort gebannt und
ab dann ging es halt abwärts
dann ging es los also da haben wir dann
regelmäßig was gemacht
wir haben glaube ich einen der
katastrophalsten staat die man sich
denken kann so nackenschlag knacken na
ja nicht ganz so einfach hatte erst mal
nichts geklappt
und was hat euch dann bei der stange
unser ja irgendwann haben wir dann
glaube ich realisiert dass aus dem
ersten video aus der grundidee hey lasst
was lustiges hochladen
ja es ist halt gewachsen und wir haben
uns immer mehr irgendwie drin wohl
gefühlt in der sache es hat uns immer
mehr bock gemacht
dann wurde das immer fest dann haben wir
immer mehr dran gearbeitet
ist ja klar ihr seid jetzt wie alt
gerade so 22 23 29
warum also in der zeit dann habt ihr ja
so ganz angefangen mit dem jahr pause
und sofort zwei jahren ungefähr 2
aktiv sind wir erst seit ein bis zwei
drei jahre waren vor einem jahr trotzdem
die frage das ist ja die zeit eigentlich
freundin die sagt bohr wie ganze mit den
anderen das rumhängen warum seid ihr
trotzdem zusammen geblieben oder gab es
nie eine frau die so an einer ecke
gezerrt hat von euren dreieck dass sie
kräftig genug war man darf sich von so
was ja nicht verblendet
ich glaube irgendwie der dieser traum
gedanke der mir hatten der war dann
irgendwie auch stärker als jede frau
sein kann für uns
ich weiß noch jan seine erste freundin
die war total da gegner oder songs kag
egal und dann kam irgendwann der tag wo
wir partner geworden sind und ich glaube
da haben wir ja da haben wir irgendwie
drei euro oder so dann gehabt mit diesen
videos in hama gedacht so ist das geil
wir haben uns zum dollar verdient und
seitdem sind wir nicht mehr davon
weggekommen egal ob als frau oder eltern
war es wird alles ignoriert der döner
auf jeden fall stärker und wahnsinnig
viele leute die youtube videos machen
wir werden auf dem video gesehen es sind
tausende aber man merkt man wirklich
dass da was das man was hat was andere
nicht haben
das kann schwarz auf weiß zu einer von
euch jetzt
ich denke mal dass man das hat was
andere nicht haben an einem
abonnentenzuwachs denke ich mal ganz
einfach oder wenn man wenn sich
plötzlich leute für dich interessieren
dann muss das was du machst ja irgendwie
nicht überall zu sehen sein sonst hätten
die die ganzen anderen leute auch schon
einfach nur gucken können und ich nicht
also ja weil sie nicht ich glaube aber
meisten liegt das daran dass man sich
keinesfalls davon abbringen lässt also
immer einfach weiter machen und dran
bleiben auch wenn man halt rückschläge
hat man hat am anfang mann hat am anfang
immer rückschläge und wir haben halt
immer einfach weitergemacht weiter
weiter weiter und uns nie davon
abbringen lassen und es gibt auch andere
leute die weiter weiter weiter machen es
gibt aber es ist nicht so dass ihr im
video seht und denkt das ist es jetzt ja
da man kann das ja jetzt nicht so
allgemein halten dass man sagt ja mach
weiter weiter weiter verfolgt das ist ja
keine hundertprozentige garantie dass
ein fakt war das ist einfach weil sie
nicht man irgendwo drin weiß man genau
also wir merken jetzt noch immer mehr
genau das was wir tun ist dass ist das
passt hundert prozent zu uns und nicht
irgendwie morgens um sieben in ein
langweiliges büro oder so man irgendwie
eklig und kaffee trinkt oder so und das
passt wie die faust aufs auge und
deswegen macht man einfach weiter und
dass es wird immer besser noch was ist
es bei euch was wie die faust aufs auge
passt
oder ist das geheimnis das man gar nicht
lüften soll weil wenn man es weiß dann
kann man es nicht mehr machen
ich weiß nicht das ist einfach die es
fühlt sich einfach richtig an das ist
einfach so die leidenschaft oder was
meinst du genau du bist nicht auf
frieden also ich wüsste darauf jetzt
keine richtige antwort aber das ist
irgendwie so man hat das klingt jetzt
ein bisschen strange aber ich finde man
hat da irgendwie so hin zum kleinen
geist oder so um einen herum der einem
sagt mach das das ist richtig und das
ich würde jetzt halt als intuition
bezeichnen dass man immer intuition
ich habe mich noch nicht so doll david
auseinandergesetzt also bei mir schwirrt
kein geist um kopf auf jeden fall ist
richtig so läuft so muss es sein
ach ja ja keiner auch gut wunderbar also
der lange doofe der dicke auf bestimmte
rollen
also wir haben ja schon solche rollen
jain ist es so dieser dieser verrückte
dieser kumpeltyp ich übernehme da ein
bisschen diese frauenheld rolle
yan yan yan bedient unseres spiels
publikum komplett also es ist schon
alles irgendwie abgedeckt bei uns
welches publikum beginnst du de
abonniert mal falls ihren eigenen kanal
am sonntag abonnieren das ist ganz nah
ich bediene kein schwule oder lesbische
publikum ja ich weiß nicht so ich bin
mehr für technik kerl typ
es gibt jetzt keine leute die
realisieren und sein
ich guck railway an der technik
was sicher auch noch sagen wollte ist so
glaube ich dass wir und wir haben uns
jetzt nicht selbst hingesetzt und gesagt
andré macht nur noch das und das erst
noch frauen kerl oder so das macht
eigentlich finde ich dass die community
hat uns da irgendwie auch so rein
gemacht weil die die sagen die finden
eine sache cool und dann also bei einer
person eine sache cool und dann wird es
so weiter gemacht dass ein große rolle
die punkte sehr genau wann community zu
dem video sagt und geht in diese
richtung also wir probieren auch so gut
das haben wir früher schon früher
schaffte man das noch dass man einfach
jedem geantwortet hat aber das klar ist
dann ist das nicht mehr so aber das
spielt eine große rolle auf jeden fall
und auch für das was ihr macht was er
will wie das macht ja viele vier ideen
muss man auch dass zusagen die wir jetzt
ein video umgesetzt haben die kamen von
leuten selber die haltung truppen und
können die ist halt nicht auch mal
gefahr dass wir in eine falsche richtung
klar also wenn jetzt einer sagt drehten
schwulen porno oder so dann machen wir
diese partie kamerun und wm ok aber das
weiß man schon selber kollegen machen
die marktlücke inzwischen seien pro
backen wenn er ein eigener kanal
das haben wir nicht gemacht ist youtube
du etwas was das wird heiß diskutiert
würde jetzt thomas gottschalk ist
youtube das fernsehen der zukunft
also ich bin der meinung ich habe jetzt
das ganz komisch seit wir
wir wohnten mal in hamburg und deshalb
lang wegen dem weil wir das studiert
haben da hatten wir ganz üblich gegen
die wollen nicht sagen damit so das war
ganz jaja so schüssel
aber das ist jetzt nicht das thema auf
jeden fall hatten wir da wir wohnten
also zehn monate hatten kamerapreis wird
ja ja ja hatten keinen fernseher in
unserem haus und am anfang die ersten
wochen haben wir so gedacht oh scheiße
wir jetzt gar keinen wir müssen
irgendwie fernsehen anmelden das geht ja
gar nicht aber man vermisst es also wir
drei vermissten es gar nicht mehr und
ich gehören auch von vielen anderen
leuten ich gucke kein fernsehen mehr
dass es nur noch schrott was da kommt
und allein deswegen denke ich dass die
tendenz wird immer weiter in die
richtung gehen dass sich auch vor allem
unsere generation oder noch die jüngere
generation immer weniger dafür
interessieren wird weil auch alles
schnelllebiger wird ja deswegen denke
ich nicht nur youtube wird das fernsehen
der zukunft aber das internet
wenn man jetzt mario barth bülent ceylan
wir geben uns noch alles otto irgendwann
wieder aufgetreten
wer seid ihr da ich glaube man kann sich
damit gar nicht so richtig
identifizieren machen ja was völlig
anderes das ist halt fernsehen steckt
eine ganze produktionsfirmen und so was
hinter und bei uns besteht das team
momentan aus drei leuten und ich glaube
damit kann man sich einfach nicht
richtig vergleichen
aber das war ja auch meine frage geht es
in die richtung dass sich
professionalisiert ja klar auf jeden
fall jemand wie sieht das ist ja schon
da ist es ist ein wunder ist das nicht
wagen da ist ein dolly da ist ein
tonmann ja es ist der hammer
ja also ich meine leute wie
mario barth die haben auch nicht auf
einer bühne mit 2000 leuten mit einer
produktionsfirma angefangen das ist klar
wir wissen nicht wo die reise hingeht
vielleicht haben irgendwann 300
angestellte den wegen welche aufgaben
abwälzen können aber mal sehen wir sind
gespannt was wir heuer wunschtraum
aufgestellt also nein ich wollte dir nur
mal anmerken dass wir im moment haben
wir eine kamera mit standard objektiv
und ein stativ okay so also wir haben
eigentlich gar nichts schlechter kann
man nicht produzieren wir haben nicht
mal licht oder so richtig baustrahler so
ein baum scheint ja ja das ist aber ganz
neu also wir haben echt eigentlich gar
nicht und dieser kanal geht eigentlich
jetzt schon gut los obwohl wir wirklich
auf diesem untersten level produzieren
und so lange das so bleibt will ich da
auch jetzt keine angestellten schaumig
haben oder so wenn es läuft dann läuft
wie sodann das ändern
ich habe dieselbe meinung aber wir
verstehen euch trotzdem oder kreis zu
schauen
ja klar also ganz kleine streitereien
das gibt es ja immer irgendwo aber das
ist auch ganz selten weil uns das
schlimmste ist wenn zum beispiel nicht
einkaufen gehen dann tue ich die sachen
im kühlschrank und eine halbe stunde
später sind die dann weg und ich frage
mich immer wo die sind dann weiß sie
schon genau wo die sind in den mägen von
zwei anderen personen aber wir haben von
vielen anderen gehört wenn man in der wg
wir wohnen ja einer wg also ist ja nicht
so dass wir uns nur zum drehen treffen
wir sehen uns quasi irgendwie 24 stunden
so mehr oder weniger leid und das ist
wohl nicht immer so leicht wie es bei
uns leicht zu sein scheint kriegen uns
einig wir haben uns jetzt seit vielen
jahren nicht irgendwie in die haare
kriegt noch nie bei anderen leuten hat
man schon mal gehört ich weiß es nicht
ok also euer geheimrezepte jung
verheiratete paare beispiel sich jeden
tag sehen und sich ab und zu beleidigen
ja ich glaube männer streiten sich
seltener weil die sich von natur aus zu
den ganzen tag jetzt beleidigen so man
baut dann immer so diesen druck dem
anderen gegenüber schon passt prima ich
gesagt wollt mal die fresse oder dann
streiten jetzt seltener weil ich schon
so immer ein bisschen hockey frauen ist
es ja nicht so frauen
der geheimtipp ist ja jetzt er wirklich
meint er wenn du jetzt eine beziehung
mit einer frau hast dann musst du dir
auch beleidigen und die dich auch weil
dann das ist genau dasselbe das stimmt
wirklich ist jetzt kein genie das ist
richtig ok alter noch mal sagen maul
oder so dass nur frauen das ist wirklich
immer noch keine freunde macht das doch
bei deiner frau mal heute abend 09 oder
fressen
dann zeigt die sofort ins bett ja mal
gespannt also viel spaß beim
experimentieren und schreibe es in die
kommentare meistermacher kommen soll und
noch mehr bekannte youtuber gibt es bei
pixum im trug zum beispiel alexy vecsey
der über das dahinschmelzen und
regenbogen spucken philosophiert das
video anklicken wenn ihr mehr darüber
erfahren wollt und auch nicht ganz
unspannend ist der talk mit white t
die ihr größtes geheimnis glaube ich
verraten im talk auf clixoom viel spaß
dabei und ansonsten bis dann